whose idea was it to do the the leash
thing me that was your idea yes because
you got a little Flack for that I know
that's wrong y'all I ain't been wrong
for that he didn't do nothing wrong like
they sound like oh I understand but he
really didn't do nothing wrong he just
was doing what I told him we just turned
where I'm from we turns up baby we
getting on the ground twerking we
getting on our knees we doing all that
we doing splits flips all day we going
crazy so I was we was already doing all
that we was on our knees twerking then I
just said pull my hair yeah see pull my
hair we gonna twerk and walk
um people get their hair pulled all the
time so I don't understand like what was
I don't that's why I didn't understand
well also as somebody who's been with
black women in my life you're not
supposed to pull the hair yeah we were
saying that too and we just got our hair
done and I'm like don't pull it too hard
that's why he just had it all like just
yeah because I'm like hold on [__] man
I just got I don't put my wig off you
doing a little too much I had to tell
them yeah for sure he was like [__] we
just gotta hurt them like [__] I'm like
I've been